welcome to this video p.m. brawny Mia is
my opponent and I'm going for the Dutch
maybe you might play something more
English like but you never know brawny
Mia huh knows don't be three ok yeah
well black is doing the same thing wow
it's not exactly what you expect so a
chick g5 hmm
hmm interesting thanks very weird so
what about this pawn my see point is
potentially week but I also attacked the
d5 pawn okay okay that's nonsense sorry
get out the deck black here on the Kings
side you should worry about his d5 pawn
that plays a bit of a bit of a strange
type of chess I had a game yesterday
that did not make it into the uploads
simply because at one moment when I had
a completely winning endgame had to
answer the door and it was kind of a
longer issue so this game was terminated
with a loss due to doorbell and yeah
that was a very strange game but he just
check um yeah made many strange
decisions and I was just totally winning
but then the doorbell saved him saved by
the bell here like in boxing so if i
take this now i'm just winning this pawn
right he has Bishop c4 bird what is the
big point
he simply has absolutely no attack here
I mean age 5 h 4 is just wrong there
because there's no support of this with
this point push he has no Center nothing
simply simply not on I'll be getting in
the center
yeah it was probably the right decision
mean in comparison to two other things
that he could have done threatening the
rook down next c6 and I've got F for
coming opening up their file okay or C 5
but see success is okay that's a good
solid move maybe you should go g3 ham
and a g3 is a goodness no he rather gay
goes into a losing end game hmm okay
and f you yeah that activates my bishop
he had to play g3 them definitely keep
my keep my bishop bad on c8 so just be
sure to 7am rook e8 next rook air-five
was also possible ok let's open it up
hmm isn't it if it's not cautious i
might even keep the pawn down I don't
but it's close stick here using the pin
and I'm threatening Bishop f5
okay so rather obvious threat but still
checkmate yeah I said it's a bit but we
had the games against him um yeah but
it's good to get this win in because
yesterday it was kind of it was kind of
bad am I had this completely winning end
game and then the doorbell saved him
okay well here this is actually very
interesting position but I don't believe
in this h4 h5 business maybe when he
takes on g6 I don't know I mean hmm what
about this pawn do you really have
compensation him check I mean the bag
that I don't think I mean this is just
nice for black I get in Queen f6 night
back d5 something like that it's just
really a big porn and she tried to do
this Jim c65 is also interesting and he
has to go g3 simply I mean I don't don't
don't get it Quincy 3 is just just very
bad if you go g3 at least my bishop
stays back and I have to see how I win I
mean probably something like this Bishop
f7 g5 Bishop g6 is good but at least I
have to do it first after this this
black just wins wins the game I'm
activating my bishop and it's an extra
pole and and so on it adds up yeah takes
d4 and white is just falling a party
okay didn't you didn't need to allow the
checkmate but it's it's a complete
complete loss okay well thanks for
watching